so the first clip that we're going to be
watching
is essentially the introduction to
madame rosa's character in the movie
this is also
the first time that madame rosa
confronts
momo after he has stolen her
candlesticks
candlesticks that she was going to use
to pay her rent
because she's running out of money so
mama
this is the introduction to your
character well what i wanted to do in
the beginning
was to light you from the back so we
don't quite see your face yet
and we only see it when you now turn
around and you say vafankura
i thought it was great that the first
time that we really see your face
is when you curse it also shows your
irreverence
uh in the movie and i think it paints
kind of a very fun and vital portrait of
a character
and here's our our little boy babu
that was two and a half when we shot he
was quite
stubborn as an actor but the great thing
about him is that every time that i
called action he would only focus on the
actors in
the scene and he would never pay
attention to the 50 crew members around
which was something quite amazing
this is your friend renato carpentieri
the wonderful
neapolitan actor theater actor that we
love
working with and here's
ibrah who plays momo do you remember
mama
how hard it was for him to do all these
first scenes when he has to be very
tough with you he really didn't like to
say any bad words to you
and i remember once during a rehearsal
he walked up to you and told you how
upset he was to tell you all these bad
things and he asked
your permission to be able to say all
these bad things at you
uh so that he could play the scenes and
you said of course you can it's acting i
won't get hurt
yeah but it was he was really scared to
death
to be able to say some of the lines of
the film yeah he was
and it was really for him i was so sorry
for him i really was
you were not but i was no because i'm a
very mean
one of the reasons why i picked this
location was to set that scene
there all this whole sequence was
actually 10 pages of dialogue
and it was originally only set in the
kitchen but i wanted to
show the whole apartment so i divided
these groups of dialogues
of exchanges from one room yeah to
really kind of
show people not only your character
but also how you lived and how this kind
of makeshift daycare for kids
was in the and also production
design wise with um
with mauricio sabatini i told them i'd
like a production
design that shows the sedimentation of
all the life so basically it's a
repository for
40 you know years lived in the
department small
child was there yes yes of course he
wasn't he was
yeah he was always there
the other thing that i loved in that
production design of the house was that
little window
from the kitchen to the living room yeah
i remember when i was uh washing the
the the dishes the dishes yes yes
absolutely yes yeah you see that little
window
which i love that scene just them
watching took seven takes because they
would laugh so hard at every time that
they
look
and it shows that you guys you and
renato the actor have a good
relationship it shows that you really
like each other
one of my favorite moments of this scene
is coming up right now
he leaves now and then right when he
leaves
you do something so great in neapolitan
when here you walk here you stop
you look at him and you're like and that
way which was improvised by you is so
amazing
because it's so funny and there you
throwing him out that was take one i
remember and you threw him with
so much strength that he actually almost
fell because you were so strong
these four scenes which were i said 11
or 12 pages of dialogue
we shot them all because of course you
know it's a small budget film and we
didn't have a lot of days
so the second clip that we're going to
be watching
occurs maybe almost uh
in in the end of the first half of the
movie
where these two characters madame rosa
and momo who up until now really don't
like each other
slowly gradually something happens in
the sequence that we will see
and that begins the process
of them very gradually coming together
and understanding that actually not much
separates them that union that coming
together is very slow
very gradual and in this clip you see
the very first
initial steps of that so let's play that
clip
this i'm very proud of because this is
the very first full
cgi line done in italy
[Music]
um
laughs
this scene here now mama remember it's
the first scene that we shot in the
movie this is day one and this shot here
is day one
first shot of the movie and we were all
very very nervous
and how did you feel mama on the first
day of shooting and nervous as usual
exactly we're all really always always
scared to death
the beginning is like this because you
don't know anybody
you just are in in a place and you look
and people are waiting for you to do
something
and sometimes it's too soon to do
something
so you have to wait a little bit and
that's what i told you
so let them wait a little bit and i want
to go to the dressing room and i want to
breathe and then i come back that's true
that's what i did you're right and when
you came back you were
a hundred percent on and uh
and it showed me a
what i like about the scene and the
character is that you ride this line
between
a woman that is is strong but also
funny in her irreverence which is a very
neapolitan thing
there's always an irony in everything
you do
that can be also quite comedic even
though it's kind of a dramatic scene but
that's
what's going on that's where i come from
that's your name
that's the neapolitan touch is that
tight open between drama
and something that can also make you
smile because of how
you convey the emotion the beat just
smile
see say it's true that's true especially
now when you
say that
huh that is very funny yeah yeah i know
grazia thank you
this scene was a very very tough scene
because even though the movie is very
socially
engaged and socially conscious in the
foreground i wanted to really make this
a movie about
the story on friendship and love of
these two characters
but of course the context is also quite
political and this scene was a scene
that was very difficult to shoot because
obviously it is
a police raid where the police is taking
immigrants out of an abandoned building
because they're squatting there
and it was very difficult
[Music]
and it was a turning point in the movie
it's the first time that these two
characters
share something in common which is their
version
of being persecuted
this is one of my favorite moments in
the movie it shows what an enormous
actress you are the way that you put
your hand
on that wall and everything that's
happening in your face right now
that is your inner life that's why
you're so great your emotion
communicates
in an instant you're born that way and
it's just
a joy to be able to work with you for
these moments
really sir
and the music here too by the way by
gabriel yared is really really inspired
i i just love his score in the movie
we really wanted to walk the line in
between something that was
quite orchestral but at the same time
current and at the same time had the
nostalgia and the melancholy of the
moment another great piece is this piece
which is the
hebraic theme
[Music]
the music that you always play in that
refuge which is basically your place
where you can kind of collect
yourself and now of course you get upset
because he's found
your secret hiding place which you don't
want anybody to enter
that set is the only set that that we
built in a studio that's the only thing
that
we actually built in the movie
everything else was actually shot on
location
except for that moment but then
that close-up is the close-up that i put
the last thing in the movie i added that
close-up that final close-up i felt it
was important for
for us to see how you felt about
screaming at him
like this and i think that it it helps
because it starts that process of
realization
which then comes to here where you
realize that
you shouldn't have behaved the way that
you behaved in the seller
and your way of apologizing or
taking you know responsibility is by
showing
the beginning of a certain openness
towards him
this scene i also love because it's rare
to find
two actors who instantly or or kind of
naturally
are in the same emotional frequency
and both of you have the same kind of
energy about you in this moment
two souls coming together for different
reasons
connecting
when you say it cozy you almost
cried there and i remember that was take
one and i asked you after
the take i asked you why did you get so
emotional
and you looked at me and you say that
same thing that you say in the movie
and that's how authentic you are you you
you feel it
and you bring it and you give it to us
and it's really
i'm very proud of you about me that's a
good that's so much true i'm very very
proud
you